[MUSIC PLAYING]
JOHN VEIZADES: Good
afternoon, everyone.
My name is John Veizades.
I'm a product manager at
Google on a product called
Cloud Interconnect.
Today we have four
speakers that are
going to be discussing
how they integrate
with our recently announced
Partner Interconnect product.
Tomorrow at 11:40, we'll be
doing a more in-depth session
on the specific Interconnect
products on hybrid networking.
So if you're enjoying
this session,
please join us tomorrow
at 11:40 for that session.
Our first speaker today
is Karun Malhotra.
He is a Director of Product
Management on NetBond
at AT&T. Please welcome Karun.
KARUN MALHOTRA: Hi.
Welcome.
And thank you all for
taking some time out
to listen to what we
have to talk about
and see how networking is a
key component in your cloud
strategy.
So just want to level
set to begin with.
This is nothing new.
All of you are aware,
all the analysts
out there give their
reports and metrics.
Cloud continues to grow.
The investment in cloud grows.
From a customer and cloud
provider perspective,
security remains at the top.
But really what I
wanted to highlight here
is over the last several
years, the conversation
has really shifted from
why the cloud and how
to how many clouds
are you connecting to,
and how do you work
between those clouds
and in a hybrid cloud strategy.
So if you look across
IDC, Gartner, all
the other analysts, and read
through all the reports,
really you can summarize
it across four variables
that you see here.
Security and
performance are what
gets talked about the most.
But really, simplicity and cost
are key drivers from a business
perspective as you migrate,
wherever you are on your cloud
journey, as you migrate and
pivot, as trends change,
as customer needs change.
And so I'm going to
highlight those four
areas across the presentation.
So just want to give quick
background on AT&T's network.
It's the prime value that's
brought to the table here,
obviously a global network.
We work through a
number of providers.
We have more than 200
petabytes of data streaming
through our network each day,
very large capital investor
bringing fiber to businesses
around the country.
So now I want to jump
into your options.
As you look to
connect to the cloud,
you have a variety of options.
The internet's there.
It gives you, through
some encryption tunnels,
you can get a level of security.
But you're still susceptible
to some of the security
threats such as DDoS.
Also have a level
of performance,
but not guaranteed.
You're, again, susceptible
to the equipment and best
effort of the internet.
And what really chimes in
here as well is, again,
cost and the simplicity.
You can get the setup, but you
may have some fixed commitments
and bandwidth requirements
that you may not
be able to easily change.
Now taking it a step
further, and if you build out
private connectivity, your
performance and security
is greatly increasing just by
getting off of the internet.
Now again, the key here is
cost efficiency and simplicity.
If you want to build
this out, you're
going to have to overprovision.
You need to plan for growth.
So you don't want to
put in small bandwidth.
You want to be able to
add where you think you
might grow and plan for that.
So you need to overprovision,
you need redundancy.
You need to get all the
resources to configure, manage,
get equipment set up
in these locations.
And then, of course,
we want to connect
in regions across the
country and across the globe,
you now have to kind
of exponentially
build towards that.
So as AT&T approached
this area, we really
looked across those
four areas and how can
we meet customer
needs and demands
based on their business speed.
And so what we built out
is NetBond for Cloud.
We preprovisioned
redundant 10 gig circuits
to numerous cloud
providers around the world.
With Google Cloud, we're
in San Jose and Chicago
and in Ashburn.
And really what this
allows the customers to do
is not have to plan so far
ahead and make commitments.
To get this connection and
security and performance
and reliability, you
can work through us.
We've done API integration and
used SDN-enabled architecture
and orchestration
on the back end
to allow for seamless
provisioning to Google
Cloud literally within minutes.
So you don't have to
plan this ahead of time.
If you're ready to go,
you log into a portal
and you get started.
And as your growth moves
across, you can easily flex.
You can start at 10
megabits per second
and move all the way up into
multi gig bandwidth needs,
again, within minutes.
You don't have to
wait, put in orders,
and go through that process.
And really tying into
the global AT&T network,
this really allows any IoT
endpoint, any remote office,
remote worker, regional offices,
call location, data centers--
everything that connects
into the network
can traverse and connect
to your Cloud seamlessly.
So this is the area I wanted
to highlight a little bit is
similar to Google's model,
we approached this base
with the customer in mind.
And so we really worked
across all the verticals
and industries and every
size customer and asked,
what are your needs?
How are you migrating?
How are you moving?
How are you growing?
And of course the needs
vary across the verticals
and across different
sized companies.
But really, we looked at
innovation and developing
into the platform
in creating features
to allow for the customer
to be flexible as they grow.
So want to highlight
in management space,
we have a simple,
intuitive website where
you can log in and manage and
see reporting, set up alerts,
all that great stuff.
But a lot of customers are
using a custom platform,
or they manage their
cloud workloads as well as
the network.
They may have a third party.
And so we API enabled all of
the service and user management.
So we have tens of APIs that
allow you to do everything
you can within the portal.
From a performance perspective,
yes, we're off internet,
and it's inherent in
the infrastructure.
But we also have
service level agreements
across four metrics, jitter
and latency, data delivery,
and service availability.
So we're not just saying
we're really good.
We back it up.
We also allow customers
to prioritize traffic.
If you're using
maybe connections
to back up data at
certain intervals,
we have video conference calls
going over those same links.
Customers were
asking us, we want
to be able to
prioritize this traffic,
and we allow you to
tag those packets.
We also went in, and
in our architecture,
we had, from certain
verticals such as health care,
requests for we still
need better performance.
And so we looked at
it, and again, you
know we've heard a
lot about multicloud
over the last couple of days.
And really, customers,
are asking I'm moving,
I have data stored here, I
have analytics through here,
my sales staff's products
are somewhere else.
So what we did is instead
of routing all that traffic
from that peering location
back to the customer's network
or data center and then
back out to the third cloud,
we inherently route all
traffic to the nearest router.
So if you have some workloads
in Los Angeles and others
up in the Northwest,
and let's say
your data center's
in Chicago, you
don't have to traverse
halfway across the country
and back over.
It'll just hit the local
router and move on.
From a security
perspective, we also
got a lot of customer
requests of I
want to add additional
layers of security.
If there's any malicious
activity in the cloud,
how do I protect my
network and vice versa?
So we allow for
customers a drop in tens
of appliances in
between, whether it's
for performance or security.
So firewalls, IDS, IPS,
WAN accelerators, anything
you can really think of, we
allow one-gig, 10-gig ports
to allow you to bring
in what you need
and manage all that traffic
between your network
and the cloud.
And then again, hitting
on customer experience,
we really wanted
to make sure it was
simple and seamless
and working easily
with the customer's needs.
So we provide a white glove
provisioning treatment.
Essentially we'll
walk you through it.
Again, it's a real simple
click-through process.
You can do it by
yourself within minutes,
but some customers are
still not comfortable
or they don't have
the expertise.
We'll jump in and help
you get everything
set up and up and running.
So another piece a lot
of customers look at
is kind of have a
hybrid cloud use case.
I have either some systems that
I already have in local data
centers.
Or maybe I have lots
of workloads there
and I want to migrate some but
I want to leave some there.
So how do we build across that?
So really leveraging
our colocation partners
and our own IDCs as well
as our data centers,
and using AT&T MPLS network,
we can bridge that gap
and really provide
from a single provider
your end-to-end connectivity
from a hybrid use
case or straight cloud use
case, and really, again,
in a global standpoint.
And so one example
I really wanted
to highlight-- this
came up recently--
there was a large home
automation company.
They have thousands of end
devices, and they were routing.
They had their data
aggregation and rules engines
and two data centers.
One was in San Jose,
one was in Atlanta.
And they were using
a cloud provider
for storage and analytics
and that type of stuff.
And so they were not getting
the performance they needed.
They were using a mix
of private connectivity
as well as internet
connectivity.
And they had some major needs,
a big shift in their strategy,
and they wanted it to move fast.
So they came to us,
said can you do this?
We need it in three weeks.
So with our solution, with
our network, and with NetBond,
we had connectivity
to those IoT solutions
as well as the Cloud providers.
We went back to them and
said, yeah, we can get you up
and running today.
So obviously we work at
the speed of your business.
As your needs
change, we can then
flex and pivot accordingly.
So really, to tie
this all together,
going back to the
four components,
security, being
off the internet,
we have additional
levels of security.
But we also-- again,
based on your needs--
we allow to add additional
layers of security.
And we continually build
within our network as well.
We have our own kind of
virtualized functions.
You can add in some
managed firewall services.
You can add in your own white
box and spin up VNFs as needed.
From a performance
perspective, we're SLA-backed,
again, allow you to add more.
And we continue to look
at our architecture to see
how can we make
those improvements
and really meet your needs
as your company grows.
But really, the two
things I focus on
are simplicity and
cost efficiency.
Wherever you are on
your cloud journey,
we can help step in and
get you going today.
You don't need to
make a big plan
and architect all
these things out.
Just log in, set it
up, start using it.
You don't need it the
next day, disconnect it.
There's no commitment.
There's no long-term
things to tie you down.
Let's get started,
let's keep moving,
and let's work at your speed.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
JOHN VEIZADES: Thanks, Karun.
And up next is Brian Lillie.
He is the Chief Product
Officer of Equinix.
Thanks, Brian.
[APPLAUSE]
BRIAN LILLIE: OK.
I really wish they'd make
these podiums shorter.
I don't know what it is.
So I'm going to talk to you.
We've each got 10
minutes, and I'm
going to try and really give
you a snapshot of the work we've
been doing with Google on the
Partner Cloud Interconnect.
We've been working with
Google for several years
now, even back to
Layer 3 peering.
And so it's just been a
wonderful relationship,
and it's come quite a long way.
So I'm going to introduce you to
ECX, which is the Equinix Cloud
Exchange.
And it really started as
Equinix Cloud Exchange
and only recently
became the Fabric.
This Cloud Exchange
started as a way,
really, to offer
efficient connectivity
for customers like Google
to multiple enterprises.
And you can see the
features are it's on demand,
it's private networking, it's
private network connectivity.
It's completely software
defined and API enabled,
and I'll show you
that in a minute.
And it's available
in 30-plus metros.
So we're in 52 metros around
the world, and Google's with us
in 21.
Well, with the launch
of Fabric, which
really is us interconnecting
our data centers together,
we've now extended
the reach with Google
to an additional 10 metros.
So it's 31 altogether.
And so you can get
multiple connection options
to Google Cloud.
You can do private
direct connect,
or you can do it over the
Cloud Exchange Fabric.
You also, though, can connect
to your own infrastructure.
So if you're in multiple
sites, you actually
can connect to yourself
across those metros,
and whether that's for
primary DR, et cetera,
or finding somebody else
within the ecosystem
that you want to connect to.
And that's really,
in a nutshell,
what Cloud Exchange is.
So where the Google Partner
Interconnect is located
is here.
You can see the
multiple locations.
These are the 21 if you overlay
where the Interconnect exists.
And then the Fabric is how we've
connected our sites together.
We're live in both
the US and EMEA.
We'll be live in
the next few weeks
interconnecting our data centers
in Asia, so APAC will go live.
As you can see, it's
dotted because it's
not general available yet.
And then what
you'll see is in Q4,
we'll be connecting the world,
and that's underway right now.
And this, really,
to us, is a way
that our customers, our
end customers, primarily
enterprises, have come and said
to us, as a partner to Google,
they've said, we want to
reach the Google Cloud.
And in some cases it
was right in the data
center they were in.
And we have 10,000 customers.
In other cases, it wasn't
where they were located.
And this Fabric allowed them
to connect seamlessly to it.
Now in certain locations--
and I'll say today it's eight,
and you can see Hong
Kong has an asterisk
there because it's coming soon.
It will be nine soon--
where you're within two
milliseconds of the Google
Cloud Platform.
Sub two milliseconds
implies that if you're
running your
workloads at Equinix,
you actually can really be
connected to the Google Cloud
as if it was a part of
your own infrastructure.
So you get the benefits.
And I've personally spoken
with [INAUDIBLE] about this,
is that when you think
about workloads residing,
and the power of Google in
particular when you think
of analytics, if you're running
your application for whatever
reason on your premise, and that
premise happens to be with us,
you actually can have your
data resident in Google or vice
versa.
If you don't want
your data there,
you can have your
data on your premise
and actually use the
applications and tools
in Google to run seamlessly
over that Fabric.
This is significant
and gives, really,
the best of both worlds.
And we've seen several
companies, organizations,
customers take advantage of
these connectivity options.
Now for the other--
so I said there are 21
locations specifically--
for the other 12,
you're still within,
in some cases, five,
10, 15, 20 milliseconds.
But this is actually
sub two milliseconds.
Now what we've spent
a lot of time on
is the developer community.
So I don't know how many in
the audience are developers,
but we've really wanted to API
enable the entire platform,
and we're seeing
significant uptake.
So we just launched recently--
this is our third iteration
of the developer portal.
So if you go to
developer.equinix.com,
you can have access to
the developer experience.
You can subscribe to the APIs.
You can see them.
All the contracts are there and
the documentation are there.
And to give you an example,
these are some of the APIs
that are available.
Now Cloud Exchange is by
far the most leveraged APIs
that we have.
And what we're seeing now is--
again, I don't know if it's
a combination of customers
or partners in here--
but if you're a partner, you
can actually embed these APIs
into your offer.
And we're starting to see some.
We just did a webinar
on this two weeks
ago with Infinidat, who
has included and embedded
these APIs into their offer.
And it's, again, in
a hybrid multicloud.
And if I go back for
one second, there's
one note on here
that just got added,
and I really want
to highlight this.
Today we use Kubernetes
to orchestrate our Docker
environment.
With this GKE
On-Prem, you actually
can run that on-prem Kubernetes
environment, Kubernetes Engine,
in your cage, in
your deployment,
and use that to orchestrate
across multiple clouds.
And so we're just now--
with that announcement,
we're just now
looking at how do we
extend our existing
Kubernetes deployment
and actually use
that to orchestrate
our workloads both on
prem and across in Google,
where we run today a
number of workloads.
In particular, if you
think about a data center,
a data center is a big thing
and it's full of things.
And so we stream data
out of our data centers,
and it's a very, very
large IoT use case.
And we're using Google
and the analytics
in Google to run
that environment.
And we expect to run more now
that we have this new solution.
So we were pretty happy
about that announcement.
So if I go back to the APIs,
these APIs are available today.
You can configure
them in minutes.
It's an on-demand platform.
And I think, like you just
heard Karun say, in this--
and I don't have today a
demonstration to show you.
However, Paul Mason-- Paul,
if you could raise your hand--
Paul's our lead solution
architect on this.
He did a session in the
floor where he demonstrated--
in about 90 seconds,
he set up a connection
to US East 4, which
is in Ashburn.
And in about, like I
said, about 90 seconds,
set up the connection,
transferred eight gigs of data
in approximately 30
seconds, 20 to 30 seconds.
And he can demonstrate
that again for you
if you want to swing by.
So this is all SDN-enabled.
And as Karun said, you can
set this up for minutes, days,
hours, weeks, et cetera.
It's a very, very nice way
to manage your connections
to the cloud.
And so we have
several use cases.
These are just a couple.
We have today over
130 connections
through the Google Partner
Cloud Interconnect.
In some cases we have a
very large retail provider
that is using Cloud
Exchange to route
between Google
Cloud environments
for redundancies purposes.
And this is to
achieve their SLA.
We have another
customer who wanted
to actually move data and
workloads out of another CSP
over to Google.
And Google actually
brought us this lead
and asked us if we could
help them solve this problem,
and we actually moved
those workloads.
And then we have one ourself
that I've already mentioned,
which is how we're using it
to run our IoT analytics,
which really leads us
to PUE prediction, which
we're getting pretty good at.
And so I would just
say visit our website.
There's one URL
that's not on here
I would strongly recommend.
It's free and it's really good.
It's called IOAKB,
Interconnection-Oriented
Architecture Knowledge Base--
ioakb.com.
You can log in there and
there's free blueprints
on how to build your
own, basically, network
diagrams for how to
build a hybrid multicloud
and with Google
prominently in there.
So I think I'm out of time.
I'm out of my 10 minutes.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
JOHN VEIZADES:
Thanks a lot, Brian.
And next up is Matt Simpson, VP
of Cloud Product at Megaport.
Thank you.
MATT SIMPSON: Good
afternoon, everyone.
Hello, San Francisco.
How refreshing it is to meet
everyone and be here rather
than, I guess, in Vegas.
I love Vegas, but I'm
sure everyone in this room
has been too many times this
year with certain events.
So Megaport.
So there's some
commonalities with some
of these presentations
with both AT&T and Equinix.
And that is giving
your customers choice
in getting to Google.
And I guess with
GCI and the partners
that we're presenting here is
extending the reach of Google
and bringing Google to you.
Today I'm going to
talk about Megaport.
So Megaport is a global
software-defined network,
and we're in the business of
interconnecting data centers.
One of the biggest problems,
and one of the biggest
questions that we do
get from customers
is I'm in one
particular data center,
but I'm looking to
access certain services
from another onramp location.
How am I going to
get my connections
and my direct access
between those two parties?
So what we've done
over the last few years
is built a Layer 2 network
across 221 data centers,
and we're data center agnostic.
So we work between players like
EdgeConneX, Digital Realty.
We're in Equinix.
We're also in
InterAction in Europe.
And what that brings is a really
rich ecosystem of services.
And that's really important when
you're looking to access GCP.
There's 4,000 data centers out
there, so we still are growing.
This quarter alone we
built into 21 data centers.
So we're continuing to build
that network out globally.
So the key differentiator
between us and, say,
a traditional network is
we've aligned our business
model similar to cloud.
There's no lock-in contracts,
you can scale on demand,
similar to the other
partners that presented.
And it's rapid.
It's fast.
Within a few minutes, you'll
be able to connect to GCP.
And today I'm actually--
pray to the demo gods--
I'm going to do a bit of a
quick demo for you as well
and showcase the
portal, and give you
a scenario of a particular
customer use case going
from one cloud provider to GCP.
So I just want to highlight
our network and the reach
that we have.
So Google has an
extensive backbone.
I think there's a couple of
hundred points of presence.
And congratulations on
the recent announcement.
I think that they're laying a
subsea cable between Virginia
and Belgium.
But beyond that there's
our network as well.
So across that, you can
scale your bandwidth,
and you can connect from
any of those data centers.
So there's 221.
But I really also want to
highlight the cloud onramps
as well.
So there's 106 cloud onramps
that we've interconnected with.
And it's really important.
We're talking about multicloud,
here, and you as a customer
looking to get direct access
to the best digital technology
so that you can remain
agile and that you
can remain competitive.
Here's our colorful
dots, a great map
just to highlight our
points of presence
and where we've
connected with GCI.
So we are available across
10 cities in 20 locations,
and you can interconnect
at any of those locations.
Today they're all live.
I've also highlighted
direct peering.
So today is all about getting
direct access to your VPCs,
but if you're looking to
access G Suite or some
of those public
resources, then you
can also interconnect via the
direct peering option there,
too.
So how do we
deliver the service?
And again, I really want to
highlight multicloud here
because I know some
of you in the room
are probably using other cloud
providers and other technology.
And how do you actually
get access to GCP today?
And so on the left-hand side,
if we go from left to right,
we're looking at our
traditional Layer 2 service.
So a customer would
essentially establish a one-gig
or a 10-gig port in
any of our data center
locations via the portal.
Once they cross-connect and
provision that interface,
the virtual cross connections,
or the VLANs to GCP
can be stood up in less
than a few minutes.
And really what we're
trying to showcase here is
that ability, if you're
using another cloud provider,
you can actually
start using GCP today.
And I guess on the
bottom here, we've
got Megaport Cloud Router.
And I'll go into
that in a little bit.
I really want to focus
on that in a minute.
So there's a couple
of SLA options
that you have with Google.
To get the four nines
of availability,
what that looks
like on this side
is two ports interconnected
from two different data centers
corresponding with four VLANs.
On the GCI, side, you're looking
at establishing four cloud
routers with four
VLAN attachments.
The VXCs, again, is where the
flexibility of the service
interacts.
And you can, on our side,
establish from one megabit
right up to 10 gigabits.
And you can change
that on the fly.
So this year we actually
released a new product.
Over the last few years our
customers were coming to us
and saying, wouldn't it be great
if I could localize my traffic
if I was expanding my business?
Say I'm in Oz, and I'm looking
to tap into North America.
But I'm not really interested
in establishing space, power,
physical network, routers.
I was born in the cloud and I'm
looking to get access to GCP,
but I'm not looking to invest
in some of that networking
infrastructure.
And this is Megaport
Cloud Router.
It's a private
Layer 3 capability,
which allows
cloud-to-cloud networking
and also enables
localized traffic.
Again, I'll point out
the 106 cloud onramps.
We'll continue to
expand with Google,
and that number will grow.
And just showcasing
that example here,
so we have a customer in LA.
They might be media
and entertainment.
They've got some on-premise
infrastructure, say,
in the Digital Realty
facility in LA.
They're looking to establish
a 10-gig port in LA.
And they are connecting,
traditionally,
with a VLAN to GCP and AWS.
And on the right-hand
side, they're
looking to expand
on the east coast,
but they're not looking to
invest in the infrastructure
there.
So what they can do is establish
a Megaport Cloud Router
within a couple of minutes.
They could start at 100
meg if they wanted to,
and then they could interconnect
from AWS to GCP within minutes
and start passing traffic
over our Layer 2 network
within a couple of hours.
So we're going to flip over.
No one use the Wi-Fi.
I'm kidding.
And I'm going to
jump into the portal.
Is everyone familiar
with GCI, establishing it
via the Google console?
Just a raise of hands.
There's a couple.
Not too many.
So the first step is you would
go into the Google console.
You'd go over to your hamburger.
And you'd scroll
down into networking,
and you would select
Hybrid Connectivity.
So there we go.
We've got Hybrid
Connectivity, and you
would select Interconnect.
And then you've got two
options, Dedicated Interconnect,
so if you're in the same
facility as Google, then great,
you could do
dedicated and you'll
get your own 10-gig port.
Then you have the
GCI partner option.
What I've done, just to
save a little bit of time
because I know there's a lot
of partners presenting today,
I've preloaded one already.
And what I've done here is
established two Cloud Routers
with two VLAN Interconnects.
So on the right, I've got
my two VLAN interconnects.
And sorry for my Aussie slang.
I've called it truebluevlan1
with truebluevlan2
against two Cloud Routers.
And these are the
Google Cloud Routers.
This is a router mate number
one and this is a router mate
number two.
So I'm going to flip
over to the portal.
The first step is you would
log in-- it's web-based, so
Megaport.al or
portal.megaport.com.
Anyone can try this out.
You can see pricing.
You can also see all of
the locations that GCP
we have enabled today as well.
So it's like buying a pair
of Nike shoes, as I say.
You go from left
to right and you
check it out and you deploy.
So the first step is I would
establish an MCR, as I call it,
Megaport Cloud Router.
And you've got the
two options again.
Create Megaport, which is going
to be if you want to establish
a 10-gig port on the A side.
And then the Z side is the
Google, I guess, location.
So here I've already
preloaded an MCR.
It takes a couple of
minutes just to deploy that.
I've got my
connection in Ashburn
in AWS already connected.
And what I'm going to do here
is just change this and preload
and configure my A end.
So I'll click onto the
vlan1, configure BGP,
pop in my AS number, which
is going to be my MCR AS.
And then I'm just going to
copy the local router IP
and enter that into the
IP address space there.
Establish BGP on the A end.
All right.
Google's AS.
The local IP is already
preloaded for me.
Again, similar to
the other partners,
we've done an API
integration, and we've
simplified and removed
some of that complexity.
I will then copy my
Cloud Router prefix.
And I'm going to
enter that in as well.
Click OK.
I'm just going to remove
that one and apply.
What that's going
to do is it's going
to push an API call right
through to the Cloud Router
and enable that connection.
So it does take a
couple of minutes.
So just to speed up
a bit of the time,
you'll see that rocket
spinning around.
I'm probably just going
to run straight through,
but just want to showcase
the ecosystem as well.
So with GCP, you're
looking at accessing
some of the digital technology.
But also, in here,
you can access
some of our NSP partners.
We've got network
service providers.
So beyond the data
centers that we're in,
you can actually interconnect
with and do last mile with some
of those partners as well.
And again, there's
a whole marketplace
full of different
service providers.
And that, again, is
adding a lot of value
to you for your solutions.
I'm looking at
wrapping up because I'm
running out of time.
So we'll flip back, flip back
to the slides if you might.
This is [? AJ. ?] Oh, yes.
Awesome.
So just recap.
In LA we've got
our physical port.
We don't have to do that
if we don't want to.
We've got a virtual
cross-connection connecting
to our Megaport Cloud Router,
which is our virtualized Layer
3 capability.
And then we have virtual
cross-connections
between AWS and GCP.
We've just popped
in our marketplace
there if you're
looking to access, say,
Rackspace or Nutanix.
We do have a booth here as well.
There's a lot of
detail around MCR,
and we've got our team
in the room as well,
so if any questions.
Again, thanks very much for
having us, and on to Verizon.
[APPLAUSE]
JOHN VEIZADES: Next
up, Ghassan Semaan,
who is a Distinguished
Engineer at Verizon on cloud.
Thank you so much, Ghassan.
GHASSAN SEMAAN: All right.
Hello.
Thank you, everyone, for
attending this session.
My name is Ghassan Semaan.
I am part of Verizon Advanced
Technology Group, where
I focus on networking
solution in general,
and for the last couple
of years, been focusing
on cloud communication.
I'm here to talk to you
about Verizon Secure Cloud
Interconnect, which
is Verizon's solution
to connect our customer to
their cloud partner in general
and to Google Cloud
in particular.
However, before I start
talking about SCI per se,
I would like to
take a minute or so
to position SCI within
Verizon portfolio.
It doesn't matter today whether
you're working on the network,
whether you're writing code for
Google, you're doing dev op.
We are all working
with the ultimate goal
of developing and supporting
the application that
runs the business.
In that regard, Verizon has
developed a large portfolio
of services that
is intended to help
our customer into the
enablement of their application,
whether it's on the networking
level with our private IP
network or MPLS,
our 4G-5G wireless
network, on the connectivity
level with secure
Cloud Interconnect itself,
or our SD WLAN services,
in the virtualization layer,
where a large number of network
functionality is
being virtualized,
the orchestration
layers that manage
these different
virtual instances
and help with the migration
into a software-defined network
and the application
layer with our APIs
and the different tools
that manage the application,
or the security layer that
encompass all these services.
We have a full
digital supply chain
that is intended to help
you with your application.
So Secure Cloud Interconnect
is one component
of this portfolio, but
it works in conjunction
with another number of services.
So why should you care about
Secure Cloud Interconnect,
and why should you consider it?
You probably heard
about all this stuff
already from the
previous presenters.
But from our perspective, we
always talk to our customer,
trying to understand how
their business is shifting,
and consequently
how that impacts
their need for the network.
So what they told us a
couple of years ago is done
are the day where fringe
application are deployed
into the cloud or where
a couple of engineers
are trying to toy with some
application into the cloud.
Our customers were
planning and are today
deploying critical application
with very sensitive data.
So it's not a surprise that
at the top of that list
they have security.
They want a network that
provide the security that's
required and necessary to
deploy those application.
More interesting
is, though, they
told us that the network
or the environment today
is becoming much more flexible
and much more dynamic.
Things are changing
at a much faster rate
than what it used in the past.
So they don't want to have to
wait for five or a few months
for a network to be established.
They don't want to be cornered
with a contract for two
or three years.
And they don't want to
have their traffic policed
for a random port speed.
They want their
network, as well,
to be as dynamic and
as flexible as what
they are doing in the cloud.
Now they are deploying
critical applications,
so they expect the network
to provide performance
that is predictable,
that they can rely on
to deploy and support
those application
and manage abilities as
well, very critical for them
so they can understand
where the problem is
in the network,
where are the issues,
and how they can fix
those very quickly.
And as nobody has
more money than usual,
they want all these
feature while allowing
them, at the same time,
to save on their cost.
So that's what we tried
to achieve with SCI.
And how did we do that?
So we started with what we have.
Verizon has a very
large private IP
network that provides the
security that the customer is
looking for, provides
the performance
with our SLA and
class of services,
and provide the manageability.
What was missing
is the connectivity
to the cloud operators.
So in this particular case,
we are showing the example
with Google.
So what we did, we went
to the different location
where Google has deployed
peering location,
and we deployed our
own physical router.
So we have two
routers from Verizon.
There are two
routers from Google.
We establish a
pair of 10-gig NNI.
So like this, we are providing
a redundant connection
between our network
and Google facilities.
So when a network in hours to
days want to connect to Google,
we start by creating an
SCI port on our router.
We connect it to their private
IP VPN network on one side,
and through an API that
we have with Google,
we establish connection
toward their Google project.
Its all software driven.
It takes a few minutes
for the whole connection
to be up and running.
What we did, too, is that we
extended that connectivity
to our wireless network.
A large number of
our customers are
expanding into the
wireless domain
either because they are
deploying more and more
IoT-driven application.
Maybe they are using
their wireless network
as a backup to the
wired LAN network.
We have gateways today that
connect the wireless network
to the wired LAN network.
So when they have devices
on the wireless network,
they can now gain
the same connectivity
and get access to
the same application
to the same set of data as
their wired LAN counterpart.
We also moved away from
the legacy-like environment
or legacy-like
model where do you
have to order access and port
and pay monthly recurring
charges.
With SCI we are adopting
the same model as the cloud
operators and have you pay
for the resources you use,
which in this particular case
is the amount of traffic that
goes through the port.
So you're not any more
constrained by a port speed.
You can burst up and
down based on the needs
of your application.
Now we took that design
and we replicated it
into many locations
across the globe.
This is showing the connection
we have with Google only.
So for those of you who are
familiar with Google operation,
you know that Google offer
different modes of peerings.
Verizon has been a
partner with Google
on the carrier peering
option for many years now.
And then as Google has
introduced their Partner
Interconnect, we are
deploying separate set of NNI
to support that
peering option as well.
You can see from the map
here that in every region
we have two or more peering
location, providing you
that way with the geographical
diversity to access your Google
facilities.
In the previous
slide I mentioned
that SCI is usage-based.
So what you can do right now
is go and deploy your SCI port
at any one of these locations.
There is no fixed cost
associated with SCI.
You are paying for
the amount of traffic
that goes through the port.
So you have the flexibility
to deploy your SCI connection
at many locations, gain
advantage of diversity
and proximity to your user.
Now SCI, like many of these
services that Verizon support,
we have a GUI-based portal
for managing and supporting
the application.
But we've been talking
about speed, flexibility,
and software-defined
network, and you've
seen it from the other
providers as well.
Verizon is working on APIs
for all the new services,
and SCI is one of those
services that's benefiting
from that development.
So today we have a
group of SCI commands
that are available for
you, and we're working
on more portals 2018-19.
With the SCI, now you
can script the behavior
that you expect
from the network.
If you're, for example,
working with us
on management tool
for your application
and you determine that your
application needs have changed
or evolved, you can now automate
the change of the network
to accommodate the
changes that are happening
at your application layer.
Now to conclude my
presentation, I'm
going to go through a quick
example of a customer who
we're working with today.
It's a large retail
customer that has thousands
of stores across the US.
They want to decommission
that data center and move
their application to the
cloud, and for that they
decided to partner with Google
to host their application.
They reach out to us to
provide the connectivity
between their Google
facilities and their store.
And for that we deployed two
SCI ports, one in San Jose
and one in Chicago,
providing them
like this with the
diversity that they
need to connect to Google.
We extended that connection
as well to their distribution
fleet for our wireless network.
One of the applications that
they're trying to start up with
is to track every
transaction in their stores
so they can know the
amount of inventory
in each one of these stores.
And as a result, they can
direct the distribution fleet
to the adequate store to ensure
that the stores are always
adequately stocked.
I talked about SCI
working in conjunction
with other services.
So in this particular case,
we are hosting for them
two virtual firewall, one
with each of the SCI port,
which will provide them with
an additional layer of security
and allow them to control
better the traffic that's
coming in and out of
their corporate network.
Finally, we're working with
them on a number of application,
too, to manage the performance
of that application,
whether into Google
environment, into our network,
the wireless network, or their
store so they can quickly
determine if there are changes
or impact on the performance
and what need to do to remedy
this and ensure that they
have the performance
they are looking
for for their application.
So it's this bundling
of all these services.
It's that digital supply
chain that Verizon
is offering to our
customer, occasionally
partnership with Google so to
help you with your application
enablement.
[MUSIC PLAYING]